hello reject nation it's Greg Alvey here
John Humphrey in this corner of the
screen we're gonna watch a movie clip
another one from justice league right
now Steppenwolf attack we've been
watching all the clips they've released
putting John on this journey of trying
to get a more excited for the Justice
League we've only seen dialog seen so
far it's working I'm sixteen percent
more sixteen percent more excited hey
let's do a patron the day shadow on this
video after the reaction portion JT JT
JT will give you a shout out right when
this is done
Steppenwolf attack movie clip here we go
this might be an actual lock crazy
justice teamfight moment or something
then see who are up against
[Music]
I love the music
Danny Elfman right now I think you're
right but I'll take it from here
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
had some teeth right there I was cool
that was cool that was me that was neat
the inclusion of Aquaman's power there
was really well done I was like oh
here's a practical way that you can help
out yeah in a non water environment yeah
and steppenwolf catching the rocket yeah
how you gonna take out this guy huh
mm-hmm I punch him a lot I really love
the music we're here like music we've
been hearing all these clips sounds
amazing and the music here for like a
fight scene doesn't sound like dark have
you you know that's kind of like Danny
Elfman right I think there was a big
deal that Danny Elfman is doing the
music I love hearing that type of music
in this in this kind of fight scene yeah
it takes you back a little bit you know
the add harkens to a different kind of
superhero movie seeing the team actually
scared was a nice feeling oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean you know that does wonders
for setting up the stakes is if your
heroes are sweating you know it's a big
deal a lot of the trailer they just look
like they're nice about it yeah they
were waiting for this to get out there
and exercise a little yeah yeah I gotta
say you're a Marvel fan boy
you ready upset one thing that DC movies
tend to have over Marvel for sure which
is they tend to have some bomb-ass music
BBS had some great music now I still had
some great music when I was Wonder Woman
the Suicide Squad had a great playlist
by David a or created on his iTunes
account is the issues I had with it
might be better in context Mardon during
his Thor Ragnarok review said something
great about when you're handling CGI
characters if you really make them a
full rounded character CGI becomes way
less distracting when he was talking
about the Hulk talking and Ragnarok and
I completely agree that's probably the
best way to put it in terms of like
watching a minute clip you're like
that's a lot of CGI water looks fake
Steppenwolf looks fake everything is
really big so it all looks very CGI but
I'm thinking in terms of context when
I'm actually watching the
movie I don't know if I'll be as
distracted by it I doubt I will be I'm
sure I'll be in the moment a lot more
well here's hoping they make Steppenwolf
a good enough character that we don't
care so much they ought to do that you
know it seems like if this guy's worth
getting the Justice League together for
probably looks like Stephen Moyer Yeah
right yeah who's playing
mance rayder oh that's yeah I wouldn't
guess yeah like Stephen Porter you know
what before this is done JT gotta give
you a shout-out buddy I sent you a
message on patreon about us doing a
Google hangout this week my buddy this
guy's from Hawaii he is Japanese he is
sexy
domo arigato mr. Roboto takes a long
time to consider before giving you a
response I I really partner with Johnny
Depp yeah he's a guy who thinks before
he speaks and I admired that about you
JT it doesn't matter what the question
is it could be how are you he will
analyze how he is before he tells you
good okay great bad terrible I feel like
killing myself it doesn't matter what it
is he will think about it before he
answers and I hope you appreciate my
tongue will already got so mr. Roboto
thing because I know you're a fan of
racist stereotypes yes to Tomo that's
what we do for hatred we complement that
we do with everything at our disposal
any reference we can find don't you want
to join us and become a patron Jack
today you could have a shout-out Justin
to this one equal to or greater than
this yeah subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell follow us
on social media we got one more clip to
check you out and take you